make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are getting back into the
x-man we are with Jonathan Hickman's
x-men part 4 now here's an important
thing I want to point this out right off
the bat one of the questions that a lot
of you guys ask is when do comic books
take place right like when does Marvel
Comics one of these events happen and
Marvel for the most part does not really
provide definitive dates they really
haven't for a long time really since
1980 something I think was the last time
they provided definitive date Chris
Claremont was the last one to do it
occasionally they will but they don't
they don't do it consistently they used
to do it back during like the 60s and
70s every once in a while you will for
example in the Ultimate Universe when
Obama won the presidency in 2008 there
was a issue of Miles Morales that had
Obama on the front cover right so it's
like okay this is when this takes place
and occasionally they will you know
depending on what goes on Jonathan
Hickman indirectly does this in the
x-men and the reason why is because what
this does is it initially picks up in
Davos Switzerland with the World
Economic Forum which is a real world
event but the title of this particular
forum is basically globalization for a
new age how to secure and maintain a
cohesive and sustainable world now for
the World Economic Forum that's
happening in 2020 which is to say is
happening at the end of January the name
for that one is stakeholders for a
cohesive and sustainable world right so
we know that Hickman is largely
borrowing the name from the current
World Economic Forum so we know that
this comic seems to take place right
about now it's a little fun Easter egg
but the entire basis behind why this
this World Economic Forum is happening
is because of krakoa one thing to bear
in mind here is that with cacao
providing all these different medicines
and things like that they can prolong
people's lives they can cure mental
illness things like that these are forms
of medicine that simply didn't exist in
the world they did in some places for
example like what Conda had that kind of
stuff but as most of you guys know in
the comics what kana doesn't really
share its resources with the rest of the
world and so because of that it's one of
these things where kirko is now popped
up and it's in a lot of ways a concern
for world economic leaders because what
you have here is a scenario where in a
lot of ways the entire economic aspect
of the pharmaceutical industry could be
completely upheaved
and completely destroyed by what cacoa
has to offer because if Ricola is saying
we'll provide these medicines and then
in turn you have pharmaceutical
companies who can't really keep up they
can't provide the same kinds of
medicines people will go to Cocola right
though they'll try to get their medicine
through cacoa
Kurkova has your cure right so you'll go
through them and you won't go through
existing pharmaceutical companies this
and the fact that Kirk Howe is
positioning itself to be its own into
nation with his own governing body is
also a concern for a lot of people
because what you have is the scenario
where mutants still aren't truly being
trusted right they're still not really
really trusted by humanity as a whole
and humanity's fear is that what Cocola
is doing is basically consolidating the
mutant population ie marshalling their
forces getting ready to go to war and
initially that wasn't the case but after
the attempted assassination of Charles
Xavier now has become a topic for a
legitimate discussion and so what you
end up getting here is essentially
Cyclops Magneto Charles Xavier
apocalypse and Gordon Gorgon is a
character that I don't really think
we've talked about before and his name
is Tommy shishito technically he's a
mutant but he's also what really he's
part of the hand and had been for a
little while
his powers are kind of split in two
different factions right so you've got
his original mutant powers and then
you've got his powers that were given to
him when he was resurrected by the hand
super-strength SuperSpeed durability
things like that a lot of that really
really all of that came from the hand
his mutant powers were things like
empathy telepathy the ability to
basically turn people to stone by
looking at them like Medusa that was
really his initial or his original
mutant ability and that's why you see
him here the other reason why he's here
is because if you notice you do have
apocalypse who's a pretty heavy hitter
the true diplomats here are Magneto and
Xavier so you've got Cyclops you got
apocalypse indi Gorgon who are the heavy
hitters who could basically do whatever
needed to be done if things went down
and really apocalypse is the one-man
army all you really need is him but
getting in here it's not designed to be
like a like a like a strike team right
they're not here to launch an assault
they're here to be diplomatic magneto
delivers this speech at the end which is
like one of the most amazing things ever
he is so awesome
but like can we just take a second to
look at like magneto with like his white
suit right like he's got this with this
white suit with like a like a purple
shirt and a red tie and like his white
hair he just looks boss it's also kind
of weird to see apocalypse in a suit the
real question you have to ask here is is
he wearing an actual suit or did he
modify his body to make it look like he
was wearing a suit that's the question
you have to ask I've got it curious but
notice this for the most part this is a
pretty cordial affair they're basically
being invited to dinner to kind of have
this sort of roundtable discussion about
how cacoa fits into everything but make
no mistake while humans here are being
cordial fear is the overriding theme of
this entire dinner and the reason why is
because what you end up doing is you end
up jumping to this revelation that there
are strike teams in the building there
are teams that have been tasked for the
purpose of 1/v a little black telepathic
attack right by
these kind of modifications are applied
to their minds and to they're there to
take out the mutant threat or at least
that seems to be the case I might off
the bat Xavier picks up on this right
and that's the smart thing to do that's
the thing you would have to expect
Xavier to me right Xavier would not just
walk into a building and be totally
oblivious as to what's going on in that
building especially after this attempted
assassination and so with that being the
case or really I guess successful
assassination in his resurrection would
that be in the case of course he can't
read their mind so he doesn't know what
their intentions are but let's be honest
you've got guys with guns who are
basically inside that base and no one's
none of the x-men are supposed to know
that they're there obviously they're
there with some measure of ill intent
and so in turn Cyclops is warned and
he's basically told hey man be aware
these guys are here will you go take
care of them it's kind of a funny thing
because of course they you know Cyclops
tells one of the guards about that whole
mutants acting on good behavior all the
kind of stuff there's been a bit of a
change here and so from there what you
end up doing is you jump into this
discussion between the various
representatives of krakoa
and the human the humans who are there
now this is hugely important and this is
one of those aspects of Jonathan Hickman
writing that I've told you guys about
where you have to pay attention right
work this will become important much
later on down the line because if you
look at what's happening in x-force
right if you look at the x-force comic
where by humans basically wants this
first strike at us it's time for us to
return in kind and then you look at this
this amounts to battle formations is
really how this is this is the beginning
of the human mutant war and so this
essentially kicks off for the question
what's the endgame here what's the goal
of Kirk OA that's kind of the question
that's being asked and the reality of
this is a somewhat of an unfair question
over the years like when you look at any
particular nation the United States or
you look at Britain or you look at
France or Italy or Spain or any of those
they they really kind of came to their
current form by a virtue of just
multiple conflicts but it wasn't as
though there was an end goal but it
wasn't as is though like when Rome was
was founded in the very beginning it's
at this point in time we are going to
achieve this place you know in like 2020
this is the end goal of where we want to
be the idea of the the nation island of
Korcula being founded was to just
provide a safe haven for the mutant
population and so when the questions
asked if the endgame here is for you
guys to just make your own your own
country than one we can't ignore the
amount of economic destabilization their
countries creating and two we can't
ignore the fear of katoa basically being
a not being an island for mutants and
then us not really knowing what's going
on and so at the end of the day the
double condom representative really
makes a good point and simply saying
every nation will
act in its own self-interest it's what
it does every nation exists in such a
way to ensure its own sovereignty some
nations will act with a more imperialist
stance which is to say trying to spread
their sphere of influence outside their
own country but at the end of the day
it's to ensure their own sovereignty if
you eliminate all the threats that are
out there and there's nobody there to
challenge you nobody there to pose a
danger to you and so as a result of that
of course you know when the questions
asked by magneto well does what kinda
want to have some kind of a formal
relationship with kirko then what kind
of like now we're good you're gonna have
to keep doing your own thing and what
Connor can do that what Canada is the
most technologically advanced nation in
the world they're way beyond everybody
else in terms of Medicine right so what
Connor doesn't really need anything core
koa has to offer but remember what Cohn
is opens itself up to the world it's now
on a grand stage so what kana is really
kind of out there doing its own thing
and it doesn't really need anything else
the world has to offer well then the
question becomes if Co is going to be a
place where mutants can celebrate their
heritage and their culture then why are
you hiding from the world to which
apocalypse immediately responds does
this look like we're hiding if we were
hiding we wouldn't be here we wouldn't
come to this economic summit yeah we
wouldn't be here to talk to you guys we
would have just declined your offer and
continue doing whatever it was that we
were doing now kind of a background here
this is kind of a subplot that goes on
is basically Cyclops really by himself
going through and taking out all these
various forces of course Gorgons there
as well but Cyclops is doing the brunt
of the work right taking out these
various henchmen
different things like that and it's kind
of a cool little scenario because from
there the various representatives here
did exactly what the x-men knew they
were going to do which was try to
reverse-engineer the various medicines
that Kirk away is supplying and one of
the questions they had is is it really
necessary to take these meta these
medicines on a daily regimen like is it
necessary to do that and the response of
magneto is yes because the way that
we've engineered this is it has a
cascading effect right so you take the
pill one day and it starts to impact
your body but eventually it'll fade but
as you continually take this medicine
it'll build on top of itself eventually
achieving that goal but the reason for
why these pills are necessary for
long-term use will be explained at the
end of the story because it's absolutely
genius and so at that point is just kind
of like okay so like at the end of the
day how should we interpret cacoa like
are you guys a threat or are you guys
not a threat and the way that my noodle
answers this is actually pretty smart he
basically says well you interpret us as
a threat because you're afraid of
anything that you're not familiar with
anything that you don't fully understand
but like any other nation out there
you're just going to have to assume that
our
is to not destroy you eventually like
treaties will be signed and things along
those lines but for the most part every
nation that exists out there is
operating in some measure on a good
faith effort in the world of nuclear
proliferation is okay well let's just
hope you decide not to push the button
one day that's really what it all comes
down to you know the hope is some
dictator does it lose their mind press
the button and then suddenly nuclear
bombs get launched somewhere and so as a
result of that magneto basically says
like you believe this because of your
history as humanity at this moment right
now you're teaching here you're teaching
your children in schools to unlearn
history and to rewrite it in the way
that you want it to be histories written
by the victor and he asks things he says
like do you guys know why you know how
it is at medieval societies got led is
because they mined it from Roman ruins
but all this knowledge was lost during
the Dark Ages all this stuff is gone you
guys don't know your own history and if
the history doesn't really seem to agree
with a narrative that you want to put
out there then you rewrite history
that's the nature of humanity that's
what you guys consistently do you change
the facts to suit your narrative and so
at the end of the day it's just kind of
like you know okay well when they start
talking about things like the collapse
of the Bronze Age humanities question is
like well why should we concern
ourselves with the collapse of the
Bronze Age and apocalypse says I was
alive then and you should be concerned
and they say well you know then tell us
if you were alive then what caused the
great collapse and apocalypse says I was
the one who caused it so it's like oh
you're talking about some pretty heavy
hitters here like they're pretty awesome
moments right apocalypse seemingly
bringing down society in the Bronze Age
which is kind of crazy but it's kind of
interesting you know because at this
point where they're kind of beating
around the bush now it's the full-on
core question that's really been kind of
lingering on everybody's mind this
entire time should we be concerned about
war and Magneto's response this this is
really mature so this is why Jonathan
Hickman writes film so well do because
he matter he does it so well this part
by by Magneto is amazing he says no
there will not be any war and when
humanity says is that so man you know
says yes it is like it is true there
will not be any war like can you see can
you not see that we as mutants have
essentially changed take me for example
in the past I would have taken all your
weapons of war all your guns your tanks
your bombs and I would have turned them
on you and he would have right we've
seen him do that multiple times during
the year during the fatal attraction
story magneto issued a blanket EMP
across the world that took down power to
the planet this is not something that
would be totally impossible or uncommon
for him to do you also get this cool
little moment
we're Cyclops is facing off against
these guys and one of them has a gun and
is going to shoot him Xavier is
basically making everybody together and
he says hey can I get a little bit of
help and like sitting at the dinner
table five floors above magneto uses his
powers and rips the gun out of the guy's
hand and it's just like damn man but
then like you basically get this this
amazing thing he says basically we as
mutants we're gonna do what you as
humanity do except we're gonna do it
better we're gonna give people a better
life than what you can give them we're
gonna give humanity a better life than
what you and your governments can do
we're gonna give them longer and
healthier existences and then we're
going to take the money the outrageous
amount of money that you're going to pay
us because at the end of the day it
means more money for you right the
government's buy drugs from kokoa and
then the government's sell those drugs
to the people for a profit of sorts like
we're going to take this outrageous
amount of money that you're going to
give us and then we're gonna buy your
banks and then we're gonna buy your
schools and then we're gonna buy your
media and then we're gonna buy your
politicians and then when we have bought
all the rest we're going to buy you
because you as humanity has taught have
taught us as mutants by virtue of
turning us into slaves things like that
by persecuting us that everybody has
their price and so once we have this
influenced once we have essentially
economic control of the world then we're
going to make sure that the wrong kind
of people and you know who they are will
not be able to have any sort of economic
power whatsoever we will not allow them
into our institutions we will not allow
them to to peddle their outdated and
dangerous ideologies and that's how your
entire control of the world is going to
end like fire without oxygen it's just
going to peter out it's just going to
sort of disappear and he says yes of
course there are going to be people who
are going to disagree with us yes
they're going to be people who are going
to hate us
that's fine they just won't be able to
do anything about it anymore and it's
like damn like we're we're basically
going to take your entire world out from
under you that's literally what he says
that's the goal of cacoa to buy
everything in the world to basically
take away any control you have on your
planet and essentially we will control
everything we will decide what kind of
education you guys get it's absolutely
genius right because it's a war that's
won without any real fighting it's a war
that's won by virtue of just saying like
we're in turn going to take over the
world by requiring you to be a part of
what we do that's why kirko is releasing
these medicines that require from
multiple regimens right taking it
multiple times because what it does is
it turns people into slaves or servants
to this medication it's the nature of
people once we cross that path we never
want to go back but we never want to go
back to the way things were if we enjoy
what we have now
more than what we had before and so
because that what it does is it switches
over to Gorgon this is one of the
coolest things Gorgon is basically
talking to these guys after having
chopped off all of their arms he
basically talks to them and tells them
you know in years past I would have
killed all of you but I think it's more
important that you spend your lives
living with your failure you guys
understand things are different now if
you guys believe that the mutant
population is going to roll over that's
not the way it is anymore and so with
all of this having been said by Magneto
being said by Gorgon and so on that in
turn by needle chimes in and says you're
keeping your finger on your ear an awful
lot so let me go ahead and solve this
problem for you they're not coming the
forces that you have around here they're
not coming and that's when he basically
spills the beans because nobody else
knew about it that's when he basically
spills the beans and says we know about
the strike teams that you had in the
building they've been neutralized and
there's no real way for them to kind of
combat that and say well yeah we have
the strike teams there to kill you but I
mean you know why did you take them out
like that's not fair you know it doesn't
really work that way
and so in at the end of the day humanity
especially United States is kind of
stuck with egg on their face because
it's sort of like you're the one that
sort of initiated this we've taken those
guys out they're no longer no longer
part of the equation anymore and so from
there you basically end up having Xavier
who removes his mask of course letting
us see his face really for one of the
first times as part of a house of X
powers of X and Dawn of X and in turn he
says is it really necessary for you to
fear us in such a way you're going to
have to trust us now you're going to
have to trust our nation you're gonna
have to believe that we want to be
sovereign that we want to be able to do
our own thing that we don't really want
to make slaves out of you but at the end
of the day that's what it comes down to
and that's exactly what we will do but
understand this and this is one of the
most important things when they get up
and they begin to leave or Xavier says
understand this and have no illusions
magneto says we've had fantastic
teachers and all of you you as humans
have taught us valuable lessons and what
it means to be persecuted and what it
means to be cast off and what it means
to do whatever it takes in order to
survive and so as a result of this you
guys struck first
you guys launched an attack on krakoa
and you guys assassinator tried to
assassinate Charles Xavier kind of
maintaining that sort of that sort of
lie then the mission was not a success
but you guys struck first understand if
it happens again expect a response we
will bring the fight to your doorstep
and that's a scary proposition because
in Apocalypse alone
he's enough to essentially wipe the
United States out of existence right if
the guy wanted to he'd wrote a 3,000
feet tall and just walk across the
entirety of the United States just
spraying energy beams everywhere and
incinerating entire cities that's the
kind of power you
and Matt's just Apocalypse that's not
taking into account magneto who can
totally disrupt the electromagnetic
pulse that's not taking into account
Xavier who can scramble the minds of
everybody on earth that's not even
taking into account the reality war
purse right so you've got Legion who's
floating out there somewhere you've got
Clinton choir who's an omega-level
telepath that you got Emma Frost you've
got all these huge heavy hitters that
just with about ten of them could
successfully conquer the world like that
and then when you take the rest of the
entirety of the mutant population on
kokoa and you add them to that humanity
stands no chance and that's why this if
anything is the most terrifying aspect
to humanity this is how the war starts
because it's not it doesn't really start
by virtue of a shot
why doesn't really start by virtue like
a potshot that is kind of the initial
confrontation
it starts with fear it starts with a
legitimate concern that if the mutant
population wanted to they could bring
the entire world down on its knees and
just leave it to burn but without being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end Jonathan Hickman is emerging
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like if you are new here the
comments explained make sure you hit the
sub button to become part of the robb
for I said those backwards uh I will
catch you guys in the next video peace
[Music]